the British PhD student Matthew hedges
who was jailed for spying alleged spying
the United Arab Emirates has arrived
back in the UK after being pardoned he
was given a life sentence last week but
was pardoned yesterday after
intervention by the Foreign Secretary
joining us groans oh cool is David Haig
for managing director of Leeds United
who spent 22 months in prison in the UAE
now campaigns for others who may find
themselves in a in a similar position
David welcome to you what we were in an
Emirati prison for and what were
conditions like we know two instances in
mind I was a managing director of Leeds
and I had a commercial dispute with its
owners they tricked me out to Dubai on
all sorts of promises and then accused
me of various things I didn't do first
of all it was thing called breach of
trust for which I was held for fifteen
months without charge in a detention and
then not much in the same way as
Matthew's case a large amount of media
attention so I was rushed through a
court process a couple of minutes each
hearing found guilty then pardoned nine
days later and then jailed again for
five months for Twitter abuse then
acquitted and then said hope and in
between that 22 months obviously as as
many people oh I mean I was tortured and
I was abused very similar to you know
sign mate sign false confessions I
wasn't allowed access to lawyers there's
the same story that you see when Matthew
talks and and anyone else that we see he
leave the Brits that we've helped over
the last few months it's always the same
story again and again and again did with
it did you form the impression
particular as a lawyer that this was a
judicial system that was rotten to the
core
was it a case perhaps of broke or judges
or was it much more systemic coming from
spreading for the government downwards
it's a system that's rotten to the core
and I mean that's accepted by our own
high courts who refuse to extradite
people to the UAE and by the UN and
various other such bodies and charities
around the world and it's exacerbated by
the fact that you cannot country space
has been so fast that the court system
was bad at the beginning but it's even
worse now because it's
not kept up with the country so you have
a system rife with corruption and where
local influences is paramount and that's
a real problem and again in my case you
know I was tricked to the country so it
was used as a corporate jail as a
negotiation tactic which is often the
case and it was 15 months before I was
charged with anything before I even was
investigated or had an interview and the
techniques you did did use the word
torture but I'm sure you use it
advisedly what was the what sort of
pressure was brought to bear on you and
why there were lots of occasions but it
was essentially to get me to sign first
of all a confession then some form of
settlement agreement and then the police
trying to get me to accentually paid and
to smuggle me out the the the jail and
across the border into Amman and you
know it was absolutely ridiculous and in
terms of senses of torture I mean
similar to what if you seen other people
that talk about torture in the UAE they
use extreme heat they use electrocution
I was beaten I spent since I got back
six months as an inpatient in hospital
and various hospitals trying to repair
the broken bones such as fractured cheek
bones and post manic stress disorder
from what they did to me but also from
watching what they were doing to other
inmates which was harrowing to say the
least and presumably I mean it sounds
like a system which didn't didn't wasn't
necessarily that concerned about the
opprobrium of the British government but
would have been inmates in inside
sharing your cellblock perhaps whose
governments wield even less influence
than ours do whose treatment was less
lenient than what you got exactly it's a
very very very racist country and and
you know the British Embassy
up until Matthew hedgers had been
following a route of quiet diplomacy and
telling all the inmates as they did with
me and many others don't go to media so
you know be quiet you have a chance of
getting out don't tell everybody what's
happening in it that didn't work each
and every time someone goes to the media
it's the media that gets justice for
people in the UAE it's not the justice
system and Matthew edges case I saw four
the first time in the foreign office
actually taking a strong position and
defending you a though is that's not
specific to the UAE I can think of two
cases in the last year the obvious one
being the Nazarene dari Radcliffe case
in Iran and perhaps less well celebrated
one being the case of the Chennai six
who were six British for you know the
case and it was only when they rattled
the cage through the media that progress
was made absolutely it's a welcome
change and it's you know it's something
that the certainly in relation to the
UAE hasn't been seen before in the way
that the Foreign Office has been
behaving and if you speak to many of the
detainees that come out including you
know for instance dr. Holman who was the
young lady and mother who was jailed for
having a drink on Emirates it's the same
advice at the Foreign Office's even up
until then had been saying do not go to
the media keep quiet and people have
been doing that and it you know they're
still there it's the ones that went to
the media and that seems to be the only
thing at the moment the UAE cares but
because they care about their reputation
and they care about and you know that
all the money that they're spending on
PR David what do you say to those about
a small handful of people those
thousands of people who in a sense
almost enter into a Faustian pact and
say okay I know that the Emiratis
haven't got clean hands it may not be
the most incorruptible regime in the
world but the weather's good the
investment opportunities there the pay's
good there's little tax you know what
I'll give it a crack I lived in I didn't
see all of these human rights abuses and
things there and then when I was there
but it's something that dawns on you and
I don't think anyone goes there perhaps
now though with more and more media
highlighting this case you know the case
of shakey Latifah who's the daughter of
the ruler of Dubai who herself accused
him of very terrible things against her
and she's missing and was kidnapped and
we're helping on that there's a
documentary next week I think now people
are at the starting to realize there is
an issue here but before a lot of people
bought into the marketing and the hype
and to the moment they might not
that scenario that you mentioned and
beyond therefore perhaps thinking about
whether we want to spend time there and
spend money there is there anything more
positively that the British government
could do I mean I I know you take the
view that sometimes we help shape their
legal system even if it's by retired
judges going out there and and
developing their legal system is there
anything else that we could do given as
you say the rapid pace of cultural and
economic economic change in the UAE that
might make things work a little better I
think the first thing is rather than
helping them make their system work
better we we have to protect our bricks
so we have to update our travel warnings
we have to update our investment
warnings to so that investors and
tourists know the real risks so they
know if they get on an Emirates flight
and they have a drink and they get off
that flight without an alcohol license
having drunk that they're breaking the
law because that's not very clear to
people you know so it's marketed as
something that it's not and that's the
first thing that we need to achieve we
need to make sure that everybody that
goes there knows exactly where they are
going and what the rules are and then in
terms of the judges that you mentioned
we also need to consider that it's not
that the judges are improving the legal
system it's something of the opposite
it's they're being paid to essentially
back up what is it what is a
internationally well known corrupted
legal system which is accepted by our
own High Court that it's corrupt so
they're essentially paying retired
judges to give some degree of false
respectability to this legal system